Bu videonun girişini hızlı yapmıyorum
çünkü size bir teşekkür etmek istiyorum.
Arada kaynamasını istemiyorum. Hepinize
çok teşekkür ederim gençler. Neden?
Çünkü Zedua öğretmenleri olarak biz
bütün yaz Milli Eğitimin kitaplarına
çalıştık. Yeni müfredatsınız siz
biliyorsunuz. Bütün yaz sizin için bu
sene kamp yapabilmek için videolarda
Milli Eğitim kitabına çalıştık ve bu
Milli Eğitim kitabından notlar çıkarttık
ve bu notlarla size anlatıma başladık
birinci videoyla. O 1inci videonun
istatistikleri açıkçası beni ve diğer
Zedu öğretmenlerini çok mutlu etti. Çok
da memnun olduk. Bu yüzden teşekkür
ediyorum. İzleyenler gerçekten bizim de
hedeflerimize, bizim de emeğimize saygı
duyup abone olmuşlar. Abone olan
hepinize çok çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Sizin bu hayatta nasıl beklentileriniz,
nasıl hedefleriniz, nasıl amaçlarınız
varsa bizim de böyle hedef, amaç ve
beklentilerimiz var. Ve bazen
motivasyonumuz düşebiliyor. Bazen
çalışma isteğimiz olmayabiliyor. Ama ilk
videoda abone olanların sayısını görünce
ben açıkçası çok mutlu oldum. Hem Zedova
öğretmenleri adına hem de kendi adıma
çok teşekkür ediyorum. abone olan ve
destek olan herkese. Benim de bu sene
hedefim 2 milyona ulaşabilmek.
1.600.000'e geldim. Artık bu sene 2
milyonu devirmek istiyorum. Bu konuda
destek olan herkese teşekkür ederim.
Açıkçası 10. sınıf video zamanı gelse de
çeksem de atsam diye bekliyorum. O kadar
motive oldum. Aynı şekilde diğer Zedova
öğretmenleri de seviyorsunuz gençler. O
zaman ne diyoruz? Ben güzel birikim
cofundan YouTube'un en büyük coğrafi
kanalına hepiniz hoş geldiniz. Evet 10.
sınıfa giriş yapmıştık. 1inci üniteyi
bitirmiştik. Şimdi geldik 2inci üniteye.
Hocam 1inci ünite ne çabuk bitti? Evet
bu 1inci ve ikinci ünitemiz çok basit.
Birer videoda tak hemen hızlıca bitecek.
Buradan çok da böyle soru gelecek
kısımlar değil ama bundan sonraki 3ün
ünite videosu gelecek. O işte biraz
zorlamaya başlayacak bizi. Asıl baba
konular orada. O o ünite bitmez. Öyle
söyleyeyim size. Bir önceki konuda
coğrafi bakış öğrenmiştik. Kitabım
üzerinde notlarımız vardı. Milli Eğitim
kitabının kılavuz halini oluşturdum.
Artı Milli Eğitim kitabında bir de sizin
etkinlikleriniz var. O etkinliklerin de
var kitapta. Onların çözümünü de
yapmıştık hemen. Şimdi ne yaptık? Ne
yapacağız? İkinci üniteye geldik. Konu
anlatımı yapacağız. Bu videodan sonra
hemen ikinci ünitenin etkinlik çözümleri
de ölçme değerlendirme çözümleri de
gelecek. Şimdi ben hazırım. Sen de
hazırsan o zaman ne diyoruz? Yunus
hocayla bir defa öğren. Bir daha asla
unutma. Zedua ile eğitim her yerde.
Şimdi sayfa 11'i açıyorsunuz
kitabımızdan. Şöyle şuradan başlayalım.
öğretmen notlarından. Bu konu da çok
basit bir konu. Bu konunun şurada
aslında neyi öğreneceğiz seninle? Bizler
uygulama kullanıyoruz, değil mi? Birçok
uygulama kullanıyoruz. Harita
uygulamaları kullanıyoruz. İşte hava
durumu uygulamaları, otobüs
uygulamaları, birçok uygulama
kullanıyoruz. Bu uygulamaların arka
planında, temelinde neler var? Bunun
biraz mantığını anlamaya çalışacağız.
Artı bize bu kısım biraz daha bunu
temellendirme kısmı. Asıl bize önemli
olan kısım şurası. Soru geliyorsa
buradan geliyor. Bu kısmı kaçırmayın.
Tamam. Nokta, çizgi, alan. soru
gelecekse bu sene buradan kesinlikle bir
10 puan var. Şimdi gelelim konumuzun
giriş kısmına. Uzaktan algılama ve CBS
ne demek? Uzaktan algılama aslında
hayatın bütün noktalarında kullandığımız
bir veri. Akışını sağlayan sistem. Ne
bu? Bak uzaktan algılama. Uzaktan
algılıyorlarmış bizi. He uydularla ufo.
UFO ya da uzaylı değil. Uydulardan
bahsediyoruz. Uydular gençler bizi şu an
uzaktan algılıyorlar. Veriler
topluyorlar. Fotoğraflar topluyorlar.
Çeşitli veriler sunuyorlar bize. Değil
mi? Uzaktan algılama dediğimiz şey bu.
uydu gelecek aklınıza. Uzaktan algılama,
uydular diyeceksin. Tabii burada
dronelarla toplanan verilerde, uzaktan
çekilmiş fotoğraflarda bunlar da bunun
içerisine konulabilir. Yani aslında
dışarıdan birinin bizi fotoğraf
çektiğini, verileri topladığını düşünün.
Biz buna uzaktan algılama diyoruz kabaca
anlayabileceğin şekilde. Tamam. Biz bu
sayede veriler elde ediyoruz. Sonra bak
bu uzaktan algılama. Sonra bu verileri
CBS dediğimiz açılımı bizim için önemli.
Coğrafi bilgi sistemleri. Coğrafi bilgi
sistemleri sayesinde bilgisayarda katman
katman kullanacağımız profesyonel bir
sisteme entegre ediyoruz. CBS bir
bölümdür gençler. Üniversitede de bölümü
var. Belki de siz gelecekte bu bölümü
okuyacak öğrencilerden bir tanesiniz. Bu
CBS'nin mantığı şudur. Verilerimiz var.
Bu verileri analiz ettik. Çeşitli katman
katman veriler çıkarttık ve bir
haritamız var. Taban haritamız var.
Böyle düşünün. Her şeyi bilgisayara
aktaracağız. İşte bunu CBS sayesinde
yapıyoruz. CBS'de bir taban harita
belirliyoruz. Mesela Türkiye haritası
koyduk mu? Sonra bunun üzerine çeşitli
katman katman veriler var. Hangisini
kullanmak istiyorsan kullanıyorsun.
Mesela sen bu Türkiye haritasında
Türkiye'deki tarım alanlarını ve bu
alanlarla paralel uzanan ya da
uzandığını düşündüğün fay hatlarını
belirleyeceksin. Mesela ne yapıyorsun?
Türkiye'deki tarım alanları verisine
tıklıyorsun. Tık haritanın üstüne bunu
koyuyorsun. Bak bir veriyi koydum. Sonra
ya diyorsun bir de fay hatlarının
verisini koyayım diyorsun. Tık
tıklıyorsun haritanın üstüne bu veriyi
daha koyuyorsun. Böyle çeşitli çeşitli
istediğin şekilde katman katman
verilere, haritalara istediğin hangi
haritayı kullanım amacına yönelik hangi
haritayı oluşturmak istiyorsan ona göre
CBS programı sayesinde oluşturuyorsun.
Aslında çok verimli bir program. Verimli
bir sistem. Buradaki mantığı anladık mı?
Ne işimize yaradığını? Uzaktan algılama
nedir? CBS nedir? Evet. Bunların mantığı
bu. Peki biz bunu hocam nerede
kullanıyoruz ki? Bakın mesela doğal
kaynak yönetiminde kullanabiliriz.
Aslında dünyada bunu her şeyde
kullanıyoruz. Az sonra göreceğiz.
Türkiye'de bunu çok aktif bir şekilde
kullanıyor. Mesela doğal kaynak
yönetiminde arazi kullanımını izlerken
kullanılabilir. Ormansızlaşma, çölleşme,
bunun yayılış alanı ne kadar ilerliyor?
Geçmişe yönelik çünkü haritaları da
görebiliyorsun. Doğal afet, risk
değerlendirmede mesela bakın tarımda
kullanılıyormuş. Tabii ki bunlar
örnekler. Bunları ezberlemiyorsun. Yani
bunlar örnek. Mesela tarımda nasıl
kullanılabilir bu diye bir düşünmen için
bu örnekler. Mesela bak tarım aralarının
izlenmesi, bitki örtüsü analizi. He
şöyle yapıyorsun mesela uzaktan
algılamayla verileri topladın. Acaba
hangi bitkiler var burada? Kayın
ağaçları mı, kızılçam ağaçları mı? Bak
bitki gör örüsü analizi yapıyorum.
Verimlilik değerlendirmesi. Bakın şehir
yönetiminde kentin büyüme hızı uzaktan
algılayınca yıllara göre görebiliyorsun.
Ulaşımı nasıl planlayacağız? Altyapıyı
nasıl yönetmeliyiz? Bunlar için hepsi
için gerekli bize. Afet kısmı için
önemli. Buna özellikle bakalım. Bakın
afetlerin izlenmesi, bu zararların
belirlenmesi, oluşmuş zararlar var değil
mi? Şimdi orman yangınlarıyla karşı
karşıyayız her yıl. Bu afeti izlerken
uzaktan algılamadan yararlandık. Sonra
zararı belirledik. Yangınlar söndükten
sonra zararın tespiti için uzaktan
algılama kullandık. Acil durum gerektiği
o zaman da bu uzaktan algılama sayesinde
acil durum yaptık. İşte bütün hepsinde
uygulamalarda gençler burada CBS'yi ve
uzaktan algılamayı kullanıyoruz.
Özellikle gençler bu CBS ve uzaktan
algılama teknolojik bir yenilik olduğu
için ve teknolojiyle adapte olduğu için
ülkemizde çok aktif bir şekilde
kullanılıyor. Bunu devlet de çok aktif
bir şekilde kendi sistemlerine entegre
etmiş durumda. Bizim ülkemiz gerçekten
bu konuda başarılı gençler. Teknolojiyi
kendi sistemlerine, devlet sistemlerine
entegre etme kısmında diğer ülkelere
göre çok daha böyle gelişmiş olduğunu
düşündüğünüz batı ülkelerine göre çok
daha aktif kullanıyoruz. Bu arada bu
konuda bayağı iyiyiz. Yani hızlı adım
atıyoruz teknolojide. Mesela burada
bakın afet risk haritalarında coğrafi
bilgi sistemleri kullanılmaya başlanmış.
Şimdi biz burada ne öğrendik hocam? Yani
bu kadar konuştuk. Sen mantığı öğrettim
sana. Uzaktan algılamanın ne olduğunu
kabaca ve CBS'nin ne olduğunu anlamaya
çalıştın. Kafanda bir şey oturdu bununla
alakalı. Tamam. Şimdi geliyoruz buraya.
Böyle bir örnek vermiş Milli Eğitim
kitabında. CBS'yi biz ülkemizde nerede
kullanıyoruz diye. Des diye bir uygulama
var. Bu uygulamayı öğrenmenizi istiyor
sizden. Yani bu ne? Afet yönetim ve
karar destek sistemi. Bu gençler bu afet
yönetim karar destek sistemi TAMP'ın
içinde. TAMP ne? Türkiye afet müdahale
planı. Böyle bir plan var Türkiye'de. Bu
plan dahilinde çeşitli çalışmalar
yapılıyor. Yani devlet öyle her şeyi
kafasına göre yapmıyor. Belirli yıllık
planlar oluyor. Mesela o planlardan bir
tanesi de bu tam yani Türkiye afet
müdahale planı. Böyle bir plan
belirleniyor. Tamam mı? Bu bizim ana
planımız. Tam Türkiye afet müdahale
planı ve bu planın kullandığı
sistemlerden bir tanesi de afet yönetim
karar destek sistemi. Ne bu? Dest
dediğimiz afet yönetim karar destek
sistemi. Bak afetlerin nerede? Nasıl
hangi şiddette meydana geldiğini bak
dikkat et buraya mekansal verilerle
belirler. Bu veriler CBS ile entegre
edilerek doğru müdahale imkanı sağlanır.
Bak dikkat et. Biz coğrafi bakışta bir
şeyler öğrenmiştik. Bak afetler nerede?
Nasıl? Hangi şiddette gerçekleşmiş? E
bir de mekan var orada. var. Bunların
hepsi bir coğrafi bakış ve coğrafyanın o
temel bileşenleri değil miydi? İşte o
bileşenler CBS ile buluşup bize IDESde
kull kullanım sağlıyor ve IDES IDES'le
beraber bir müdahale imkanı sunuyor.
Yani IDES dediğimiz şey temelde kısacası
coğrafi bilgi sistemlerini, CBS'yi,
coğrafi bakışı, mekanı, neden orada
nasıl olmuş bütün hepsini alıp kullanan
sistem IDES. Bunu afetlerde
kullanıyorlar. Tamam, mantık bu. Milli
Eğitim kitabında aşırı karmaşıktı
gençler. Ben tamamıyla toparladım bunu.
Şimdi Aydes bir daha şu başlığı tam
anlaman için söylüyorum. Bakın TAMP
neydi? Türkiye afet müdahale planıydı.
Değil mi? Bu müdahale planı çatı plan.
Bu çatı planın altında IDES vardı. Des
gençler üç tane bileşenden oluşuyor.
Yani biz IDES'te olay komuta sistemi,
mekansal bilgi sistemi, iyileştirme
sistemi diye üç bileşenimiz var. Dedik
ya IDES CBS'yi kullanıyor. Bunu
kullanırken nasıl kullandığını
anlatacağım şimdi sana. Mesela bunlardan
birincisi olay komuta sisteminde nasıl
kullanıyor bunu? Bak adına bak. Olay
komuta sistemi. Aslında insanlar deprem
olduğunda ya da herhangi bir doğal afet
olduğunda bu insanların hızlı
haberleşmesi gerekiyor değil mi? Kimler
nereye gidecek? E belki öyle bir olacak
ki bütün ekipler aynı yere gitmiş. Bir
bakmışsın e diğer taraftakiler boş
kalmış. Yardım edilememiş. Bu
koordinasyonu sağlamak lazım. İşte bu
olay komuta sistemi. Bak adı üstünde
zaten. Olayları komuta edecek sistem bu.
Yani ekiplerin hangi mahalleye,
hangilerinin hangi mahalleye,
hangilerinin hangi bölgeye gideceğini
SMS'le, maille hızlı bir şekilde
koordine edip yönlendiren sistem bu.
Tamam. Diğeri mekansal bilgi sistemleri.
Bak mekansal bilgi sistemi. İsme bak.
Mekanı belirliyor. Bir olay yaşanmış.
Mesela bakın bir sel baskını yaşanmış.
Şöyle bir sel baskını yaşanmış. Bu
bölgede su altında kalan alanların
harita üzerine işaretlenerek riski
bölgelerin tespi. Mekansal bilgi
sistemi. Mekanın tespitini sağlıyor
bize. Bir önceki ne yapıyordu olay?
komuta sistemi he olayın hemen gidilmesi
için müdahalenin oluşabilmesi için
koordine ediyordu. Mekan ne yapıyor?
Mekansal bilgi sistemi mekanı belirleyip
haritaya işaretliyor. Bu iyileştirme
sistemi ne yapıyor? Adı üstünde aslında
çok basit. Bakın iyileştirme sistemi de
afet sonrasındaki süreçte bölgede nasıl
iyileştirme yapılacağını belirliyor.
Şimdi en başa alıyorum. Sanki böyle çok
karmaşıkmış gibi geliyor size. Burada
zaten sizin böyle ezberlemeniz gereken
bir şey yok. Sadece şu IDES'in şu
bileşenlerini, tablosunu bilseniz yeter
size. Mesela bu kadar mantığı kavratmaya
çalışıyorum sana. Ben şimdi burada sanki
sınıfta ders anlatıyormuş gibiyiz sana
çok ayrıntılı anlatıp mantığı
kavratıyorum. Mesela bunların genel
tekrarlarında en önemli yerlerini
anlatacağım sana. Şimdi ne öğrendik?
CBS'nin ne olduğunu, uzaktan algılamanın
ne olduğunu öğrendik. Bunlar ne işimize
yarıyor? Bunu gördük. Sonra dedik ki bu
CBS TAMP denilen Türkiye afet müdahale
planının çatı planının altında IDES
varmış. Bu IDES tarafından
kullanılıyormuş. Bakın şu an genel
tekrar yapıyorum. kafanda otursun diye.
Bu ADES'te üç tane bileşenle bu işi
yapıyormuş. Bir tane olay komuta sistemi
varmış. İnsanlar bir afet yaşandığında
hemen koordineli bir şekilde gitmesini
sağlıyormuş SMS'lerle. Sonra mekansal
bilgi sistemi varmış. O olayı haritaya
işlememizi, mekanı işlememizi
sağlıyormuş. Sonra da iyileştirme
sistemi varmış. Olay yaşanıp bittikten
sonra hangi bölgeye nasıl bir
iyileştirme yapacağız? Bunun tespiti
için varmış. Tamam mıyız buraya kadar?
Tamam. Mesela bakın 2020'de Elazığ
depreminde bu IDES sistemi kullanılmış.
Şimdi birinci kısmı bitirdik. İkinci
kısım asıl soru sınavda yazılda çıkacak
soru buradan nedir? Mekansal verilerin
haritalarda gösterim. Şimdi gençler
bizim için en değerli şey bu müfredatta,
yeni müfredatta harita okuma becerisi
kazanmak. Harita okuma becerisi
kazanırken de çeşitli yöntemler
kullanıyoruz biz. Bunu göstereceğiz
size. Şimdi bunlardan bir anahtar
kavramlarımızı öğrenelim. Şöyle mekansal
veri ve mekansal olmayan veri diye bir
kavramımız var. Bak mekansal veri diyor
bana. Yani bak bir varlık ya da olayın
yeryüzündeki orayı geç bak konumunu
gösteren bilgiler bunlar. E bir mekansal
veri. E bir mekan var bir konum
gösterecek demek ki diyeceksin. Buna
örnekler sorulabilir sana. Hangisi
mekansal veridir? Hangisi mekansal veri
değildir diye. Bakalım. Bak İzmir'in Ege
bölgesinde yer alması. Bak bir mekandan
bahsediyor. Görüyor musun? İzmir Ege
bölgesindeymiş. Bir konumdan yani
temelde temelde şunun altını çizmeni
istiyorum. Şöyle nerede? Nerede? Yani
İzmir'in Ege bölgesinde. Nerede? Ege
bölgesinde. Ha bu mekansal bir veri bir
konum belirtiyor. Diğerine bak. Dicle
Ehrin Güneydoğu Anadolu'da olması bak
neredeymiş? Güneydoğu Anadolu'da nerede
sorusunun cevabı bize mekansal veriyi
veriyor. Bir okulun haritadaki
koordinatları bak koordinatları bize bir
konum veriyor. E bu da bize mekansal bir
veri demek ki nerede olduğunun cevabını
verdi. Diğerine bakıyorum. Mekansal
olmayan veri. Bu da konumu bilinen bir
yere ait açıklayıcı ve tanıtıcı
bilgilerdir. Ne demek? Bak mekansal
olmayacak. Buranın konumu belli zaten.
Burayı tanıtan bilgi vereceksin bize. Ne
demek? Dicle Nehrinin uzunluğu 1900
kmir. Ya bak şimdi Dicde Nehri var.
Nerede olduğunu söylemiyor bize.
Konumunu söylemiyor. Bunu tanıtan bir
bilgi veriyor. Ha burada mekan yok.
Burada mekansal olmayan bir veri var.
Bakalım. Okulun öğrenci sayısı 850'ymiş.
Bak bir mekan konum var mı? Yok. O zaman
mekansal olmayan bir veri var burada.
Yani temel olarak ikisini tekrar şöyle
bir genel tekrar yapalım. Ayıralım.
Mekansal veriler haritada nerede
sorusuna cevap verir. Konumu belirtir.
Yani mekansal olmayan veriler nasıl, ne
kadar sorularına cevap verir. Yani o o
yer hakkında bilgi verir bize. Mantığı
anladık mı? Zeduva yayınlarının
stüdyoları Ankara'dadır. Bak mekansal
bir veri söyledim sana. Zeduava
yayınlarının stüdyoları 6 taneden
oluşmaktadır. Şu an 6 tane. İnşallah 8'e
9'a kadar çıkacak. Bak bir mekan var mı?
Bak konum var mı? Yok. Zeduma
yayınlarının stüdyoları 6 taneden
oluşuyor. Bak bir bilgi var değil mi?
Ben şu an kendi evimdeyim gençler. Ev
stüdyomdayım. Ocak gibi. Ben de
Ankara'ya stüdyoya Ankara'ya
taşınacağım. Zedova öğretmenlerinin çoğu
orada. Ben şu an bu videoları çekip
gideyim dedim. Belki bir sorun yaşanır,
videolar aksar diye. Tabii bir de ince
doğacak. O yüzden hemen gidemedim. Yani
bu videoların tahminim yarıdan sonrası
Ankara stüdyolarımda olacak. Buraya
kadar tamam mıyız? Kafamıza oturdu mu?
Tamam. Güzel. Şimdi geliyoruz buraya.
Şimdi mekansal veri ne dedik? Sonra bir
de mekansal olmayan veri dedik, değil
mi? Bakın başlığa. Mekansal verilerin
haritalarda gösterilmesi başlığı. Sen az
önce mekansal veri tanımını öğrendin. Ha
bunlar konum gösteren, nerede cevabını
veren veriler? Bunları biz gençler
nokta, çizgi, alan olarak ayırıyoruz ki
sana sorulacak olan soru budur.
Haritalarda nasıl gösteriyoruz diye.
Bakın hemen şu haritayı açayım. Bakın
çizgi nasıl çizgi? Bakın bu bir fay
hattı haritası. Şu fay hattı gençler
Kuzey Anadolu fay hattı. Şurası Doğu
Anadolu fay hattı. Burası da Batı
Anadolu fay zonu. Bu çizgilerde bakın
fay hatları. Şimdi bak fay hatlarını
nasıl göstermişiz biz? Çizgiyle
göstermişiz. Tamam. Bazı verileri konum
mekansal verileri çizgiyle gösteriyoruz.
Ne bunlar? Çizgisel verinin ne olduğunu
gördün mü haritada? Evet. Peki bunlara
neler bunlar? Çizgiyi açayım. Bak sen
yolu ne ile göstereceksin? E yol böyle
çizgi halinde uzanmıyor mu? E o zaman
yolu çizgiyle göstereceksin. Sana
soracaksa bunları soracaklar.
Aşağıdakilerden hangisi test sorusu
olarak artık sorulmaz da. Ya da şöyle
yukarıda bir harita gösterilmiştir. Bu
haritada mekansal veriler aşağıdaki
yöntemlerin hangisiyle gösterilmiştir?
Mesela fay hattı gösterir sana. Yol
gösterir. Ha yol çizgiyle gösterilir.
Akarsular. E akarsular da çizgiyle.
Mesela bakın şurada. He burada akarsu
yok. Akarsuları kaldırmışım. Burada
akarsu olsaydı şöyle akıyordu. Bakın
şurada kızılarıma şöyle gelecekti. Bakın
çizgiyle gösterilecek. Yol akarsu. Fay
hattı. Az önceki haritada fay hattı
vardı. Demir yolları çizgiyle
gösterilir. İl sınırları çizgiyle
gösterilir. Değil mi? İllerin
sınırlarını bir çizgi çizmen gerekiyor.
Türkiye'nin sınırları mesela illerin
sınırları çizgi. Hangilerinin çizgiyle
gösterebileceğini anladığında iş
bitiyor. Başka hocam bak bir de noktasal
yöntem varmış. Şuraya geliyorum
haritaya. Burada nokta hangisi? Bakın
şurada bir nokta var. Burada noktayla
gösterilmiş. Peki noktayla neleri
gösterebiliriz? Daha küçük olanlar
bunlar gençler. Bakın okul. Okulu sen
çizgiyle gösteremezsin. Okul küçük
görünür haritada. noktayla gösterirsin.
Evimiz, lokanta, bir deprem merkezi,
nokta koyarsın deprem merkezine. Otobüs
durağı bunlar noktayla gösterilir. Küçük
yerler bunlar. Şunu kaçırmayın ama. Şu
noktasal veri ve çizgisel veride
koyduğumuz noktanın büyüklüğü o yerin
büyüklüğünü göstermiyor bize. Yani
şuraya geldik. Burada bir merkez
gösterilmiş. Bakın bu noktanın
büyüklüğüne göre burası büyüktür ya da
küçüktür demiyoruz. Sadece yer
işaretlemek için bunu yapmış. Ya da
şuradaki çizgi yönteminde bu fay
hattının gerçekten büyüklüğüne göre
yapılmamış. Yapılmıyor bu çizgi. Tamam.
Yani bu fay hattı şurada çok kalın. O
zaman bunu böyle daha kalın yapalım.
Şurada ince ince yapalım değil. Bize
demek ki gerçek genişliği göstermiyor.
Alansal yöntemde neler var? Bakın
haritada hemen göstereyim alan
yöntemini. Bakın bir alanı alanı
boyamış. Görüyor musunuz? Bak bir alanı
boyamış. Bu volkanik araziler bu arada
Türkiye'deki volkanik araziler. O morla
gösterilenler. Bir alan gösterimi var.
Bakın koca bir alan. Koca bir alan. Peki
alansal yöntemde neler var? Ormanları
noktayla değil de daha alanla
gösterirsin. Göl daha büyüktür. Alandır.
Bakın şu kocaman göl. Nasıl göstereceğim
bunu? Alanla gösteriyorsun. Tarım
alanlarını, yerleşim alanını, çölleri,
bunları daha böyle geniş olduğunu
düşündüğünüz şeyleri de alan yöntemiyle
gösteriyoruz. Evet, buraya kadar tamam
mıyız? Şöyle şimdi en başa dönüyorum.
Bir özet geçeceğim sana. Bugün ne
öğrendik? Aslında çok bir şey
öğrenmedik. Sadece kafamızda otursun
diye ayrıntılı ayrıntılı anlatıyorum
sana. Ne öğrendik? Bir hem de özet
olsun. Uzaktan algılamanın ne olduğunu
öğrendik. Ha, uydularla yapılıyormuş,
veriler toplanıyormuş. İşte o dronelarla
da yapılabilir. CBS'yi öğrendik. CBS
neydi? Bilgisayar programında haritayı
koyuyorduk. Üzerine katman katman
verileri koyuyorduk. İşte tarım
arazisidir, bitkidir, bitki örtüsüdür,
akarsudur. Bütün verileri üstüne katman
katman koyup istediğimiz haritayı
oluşturmamızı sağlıyordu CBS. Sonra ne
yaptık? Sonra geldik bu CBS'yi ülkemizde
kullanıyormuş. Nerede kullanıyormuş?
Tamp denilen Türkiye afet müdahale
planında IDES sisteminde kullanıyormuş.
Bu IDES sistemi neymiş? Afet yönetim
karar destek sistemiymiş. Afetleri
yönetiyor aslında.
Affet afetlerle alakalı. Bunu öğrendik.
Sonra bu IDES sistemi üç tane bileşenden
oluşuyormuş. Bir tanesi olay komuta
sistemi. Olaylar yaşandığında insanların
hemen entegre bir şekilde doğru
gitmesini sağlayan SMS'ler, mailler
atıyormuş. Sonra mekansal bilgi sistemi
olayın yaşandığı mekanın harita
işaretlemesini yapıyormuş. Diğeri de
olay yaşanıp bittikten sonra bu bölgeyle
alakalı iyileştirmeler sağlıyormuş. Bu
da tamam. Sonra geldik mekansal veri
nedir dedik. Mekansal veri konumla
gösterilen nerede sorusunun cevabını
veren bilgilerde Doğu Anadolu'dadır. Van
Gölü bak mekansal veri. Bir de mekansal
olmayan veri vardı. Bunun içerisinde
konum olmayacaktı. Sodalı bir göldür Van
Gölü. Bak konum yok. Tanım var. nasıldır
sorusunun cevabını verdi. Sonra geldik
mekansal verilerin haritada gösterimine,
çizgi yöntemiyle gösterim, akarsu,
fayadı, demir yolu, il sınırları, çizgi
noktayla gösterim, okul, dershanen,
otobüs durağı bunlar noktayla
gösteriliyordu. Alansal gösterimde daha
geniş yerleri, çöl bölgesini, ormanlık
bölgeleri bunlara alanla gösteriyordu
dedik. Ve bir sonraki videoda ikinci
ünite ölçme ve değerlendirme cevaplarını
yapacağız diyoruz ve ekranı büyütüyoruz.
Evet gençler bu konumuz da bitti. Bu ilk
iki ünite kolaydı. Hiç böyle layl lom
olduğuna bakmayın. 3ün ünitede işler
zorlaşacak. 3ün ünite videolarını
dikkatli bir şekilde dinliyorsunuz. Ne
diyoruz o zaman? Yunus hocayla bir defa
öğren. Bir daha asla unutma. Zedua ile
eğitim her yerde. Pardon böyle
bitmiyordu videolar. Kömürden elmasa
dönüşebilmeniz dileğiyle.